the NRA boycott has mushroomed to more
than a dozen major corporations cutting
ties with the Second Amendment group and
they include Delta and United Airlines
meanwhile President Trump criticized the
first responders at the Parkland Florida
school shooting after reports surfaced
that as many as four deputies took cover
instead of pursuing the shooter the way
they performed was frankly disgusting
they were listening to what was going on
you don't know until you test it but I
think I really believed I'd run in there
even if I didn't have a weapon and I
think most of the people in this room
would have done that too but the way
they performed was was really a disgrace
joining us now to react to the latest on
the shooting is White House deputy press
secretary
Hogan Gidley Hogan great to have you in
tonight you worked a long day today
thank you for coming absolutely so I
want to get into what the president's
reaction was but first I want your
reaction to what we uncovered tonight
about the sheriff Israel who is it's
quite a piece of work and now we find
out that they're sending over around
these system-wide emails to all the
officers saying support the sheriff
support the sheriff sounds like they're
cya
mode over there what was your take well
you were right when you point out them
the point here is to find out what
exactly happened for him to use this
time to go out on this political tour
trying to bolster his own political
agenda which is a gun grab which is so
fascinating because Democrats in these
times as you know go immediately to
ending the Second Amendment and taking
our guns let the government protect you
well we've seen what the government did
at the FBI we saw what it did at the
local level and now we saw deputies
outside who were trained and had guns
and didn't go in so if it comes down to
I get to protect myself with my own gun
or I'm gonna let the government do it
I'll take myself every day of the week
it's very odd that the authorities saw
Isis flagged and one of these visits and
was obsessed with Isis and I would think
that a kid who was like amassing these
weapons obsessed with Isis it's talked
about school shooting that's like that's
kind of an easy one happen but you
probably don't get all those factors
together Andy tortures animals you don't
get all those factors to
very often it's so sad what was missed
here and what could have been avoided I
mean you you know the president had an
incredible meeting with grieving parents
and and grieving children students
people from around the area who were so
just angry and frustrated and furious
but also just so sad at what happened
and now we know so much of this could
have been prevented had any of these one
flags been taken through the proper
channels this could have all been been
stopped and that's what makes it so so
egregious what about my suggestion that
the president asks sessions to
investigate this that's a very
interesting suggestion I mean obviously
the president wants to get to the bottom
of this as he trusts the floor at
Florida law enforcement to investigate
this the state rick scott said they're
going to do that today well I haven't
spoken to him directly about that but I
will say that the DOJ obviously does
have a role here if it so chooses the
media is they're obsessed with the
Republicans relationship with the NRA
what is the president's view on these
boycotts well I mean look this is this
reminds me so much of this is a much
more grievous issue but I mean remember
when when everyone came out against the
Dixie Chicks it was kind of their
blowback for what they said about
President Bush when they were on for
shut up and made a lot of headlines
I heard about that yeah I heard about
that know the author but this is a type
of thing that is ridiculous from the
standpoint of we have a Second Amendment
in this country the president supports
that Second Amendment supports the NRA
the NRA supports this president and
corporations can do what they want to
but to kowtow to pressure like this on
something that is written in our
Constitution that's afforded to every
human American citizen is absolutely but
the president is in favor of some
perhaps new restrictions get rid of the
bump stocks for sure that's obvious for
him perhaps still raising the age for a
purchase first time purchase of a
semi-auto rifle is he in favor of that
or no well look we had a meeting today
so it's interesting you bring this up
because other than the Grievous families
we talked about and the students that
were so distraught we also met with law
enforcement officials then today at the
White House we have governor's from
across the country Republicans and
Democrats dozens of them and what
Consensus it and they wanted didn't
bring in on assault weapons they want to
raise the age if they didn't bring up
the age raising one time in that meeting
and again the president's listening to
all the stakeholders here and when you
sit with the governor's at the local
level who could could help stop some of
these shootings when they don't bring it
up that's very telling to him well as we
go to war at 18 and you voted a rifle at
18 I guess I mean I'm not even making a
comment on it one way or another but we
let people do a lot at 18 maybe we
should raise the age of everything to 21
and it's it's very inconsistent it's the
question what about the daca decision
the Supreme Court decides not to for now
take the case what's the
administration's reaction it's face the
simplicity of it and I think your
viewers can understand this Democrats
say that the the President Barack Obama
was was well within his rights it was an
unconstitutional wasn't unlawful he has
the power as president to establish daca
and start daca will play it out
logically if he has the power to start
daca and doesn't this president have the
power to stop daca it would make sense
that if it's a presidential power the
problem is it's not it's
unconstitutional it's unlawful we're
upset by the decision eventually this
has to get solved one way or the other
that's the Ninth Circuit they don't you
the court doesn't usually like that so
you're gonna go back to the Ninth
Circuit who's there then you go back to
the Supreme Court and they might accept
the case on certiorari at that point
it's gonna be a lot longer than we had
anticipated
Hogan thanks for working the double duty
for us tonight always